hi Samuel here I hope you're having a
fantastic day it is Christmas tomorrow
how exciting is that I wanted to give
you an early Christmas present which was
the five most common mistakes that
property investors make hopefully you
won't make any of these mistakes going
into the new year so number one is most
property investors buy I've said this
before it's the biggest mistake they buy
with their feelings and not with their
formulas so I know it's like Christmas
time but if you're buying properties
this Christmas and you're buying
properties in the same way that you buy
presents which is ooh I like that and
it's all of your feelings that's not how
you should be investing you should be
investing with your formulas and then
the money that you make spending that
money with your feelings that's okay but
that's the biggest thing that most
investors do wrong they'll look around
the street they'll check the neighbors
they'll see if they're okay would I live
in it myself
that doesn't matter the only thing that
matters is how much we rent out for and
what's the deal what all of the formula
so that's the biggest I think mistake
the second biggest mistake is that
property investors often think that they
have to buy close to home so they think
that they have to borrow their doorstep
otherwise it just won't work and they
might happen to live in an area that
doesn't work very well for investing so
if you live in a city or a town or a
village that doesn't work for investing
then hey why not buy outside of your
area so that's mistake number two
thinking that you can only buy in your
area mistake number three which is kind
of the opposite is investors who buy
outside of their area but they don't do
any market research they don't do any
due diligence they don't figure out what
the area is like what the demand is like
how much the properties are going for
what kind of tenants they're get I mean
I will buy blind in one sense because I
won't necessarily physically look at the
property but I will do my market
research because if you don't know
exactly what the numbers are and what
the demand is and what the supplier is
then you can't calculate the correct
formulas and the deal falls on its face
yes don't necessarily buy only in your
own area but if you're moving outside
your area make sure that you do you're
correct proper due diligence and market
research number four the fourth biggest
mistake that investors make when buying
properties is they do
themselves if some of the investors the
liner who aren't investors they're
actually landlords their landlord first
and yeah maybe an investor when we need
to be investor first landlord second
some of them you could ring them right
now on Christmas Eve pretending to be a
upset tenant and they would answer the
phone
what a terrible business you might have
a hundred houses but you haven't really
got a hundred houses in fact you've got
a hundred headaches and if you do
everything yourself that's not financial
freedom we call that a rope around your
neck you want a business not a job the
thing to do is to get get us a set up
whereby you've got good people in place
doing the work for you you've got good
managers I personally have got a
property managers that manage all my
properties and then I've got an overseer
and the overseer is the person who
chases the property managers and
oversees the managers on the overseer
one person is the only person who's
allowed to speak to me and guess what
he won't contact me on Christmas Day you
want to systemize business so don't do
everything yourself another thing that
can lead to is if you do everything
yourself because it's not physically
possible is on Christmas Day for
instance or just generally speaking if
you've got lots of complaints or
problematic tenants with your issues you
bury your head in the sand and you think
I'm gonna do all of it and then it just
gets worse and worse and worse so don't
try and do everything yourself
just get a good system in place number
five this is a massive massive mistake
which is costing you hundreds of
thousands of pounds biggest mistake
number five most property investors
don't buy enough properties enough I
look back 10 years ago when I started
investing I'm just thinking oh my
goodness why didn't I try and buy more
properties I've seen over the last 10
years some of them have doubled in value
and I'm like oh I thought I'd just
bought more at the time it always feels
like shall I buy a show I'm not buying
properties you're always going to be
safe buying properties as long as you
don't make these kind of mistakes as
long as you get good systems in place
you have good people to manage the
business you're buying the right
properties with the right power team
with the right market research as long
as you get that right go and buy as many
properties as you can because when you
buy property you get paid twice once in
capital appreciation and once you rent
so those are the mistakes I hope you
have an absolute
beautiful Christmas and I look forward
to seeing you very very soon
god bless thank you so much for watching
this video it's mentoring on a Monday
every single week at 7 p.m. on a Monday
between 8 p.m. I'm gonna be live
answering all your comments and
questions don't forget to subscribe
right over here so you'll never miss one
of these videos I'll see you next week
at 7 p.m. also if you haven't got a copy
of my book you need this in your life
you can get it from Amazon for 10 power
19 iron or a gift from made absolutely
free down below in the description link
I'll see you next week monday at 7 p.m.